hello and welcome to the pledge there
was a feline of confusion at a press
conference in Pakistan this week as the
hapless human responsible for filming a
politician's press conference
accidentally switched on the cat filter
while live-streaming the offense on
Facebook now it was a number of minutes
before the mistake was rectified
something that we on the pledge would
never be as careless as to let happen
coming up on the program
Rachel argues a step up for one isn't
good for all michelle goes on more than
and Trevor wants sixteen-year-olds off
city streets but first it's Nick now
remind me Trevor what's that golden rule
about telling jokes oh you mean the
secret of great comedy mning that's
right and that's precisely where we
should file the Rauh over the so called
gag from the so-called comic Joe brand
concerning acid attacks on politicians
miss Brand who I found find about as
funny as a troubling case of piles chose
to sing laughs by suggesting that
instead of milkshakes we should be
certain battery acid over certain
vertical figures and it's 99% certain
she met Nigel Faraj this is where the
timing comes in five years ago this joke
was lame and lackluster but allowable
three years ago almost to the day the
landscape changed when a British
politician was assassinated on the
streets of West Yorkshire there is now a
dangerous toxicity and malevolence in
the air it falls to broadcasters comics
and politicians to try to calm down this
frenzied anger the BBC which broadcast
this joke 20 days after it was taped is
shameful in its lack of action and just
a warning this debate contains language
we some viewers might find offensive
[Music]
Nicoll too pricey okay not a great joke
but it's a bit rich coming from a former
Sun columnist in the era of gotcha
and Freddie star ate my hamster to be
having a go Joe brand owners let me
declare an interest I'm a chair of
something called index on Censorship
there's a global campaign for freedom of
expression and that's just part of a
great British tradition of how we get
things change invective insult argument
back in 1729 the great satirist Jonathan
Swift wrote Gulliver's Travels wrote an
essay called a modest proposal what he
proposed was that poor people should
sell their children their babies to rich
people so that they wouldn't have to be
burdened by them and rich people would
have a new source of nourishment
now this shocking and it's disgusting
but it drew attention to the lamentable
levels of poverty now what you're saying
I say I'm too really surprised at you
it's taking us into the territory where
nobody is allowed to shock nobody is
allowed to say things are not as they
should be and that I am going to shock
you out of complacency my central point
is it was fine until someone did
actually kill an MP that that is the
difference I don't know I hear what you
say the son was 35 years ago because of
events three years ago almost to the day
I think it's changed back to you in a
moment Rachel well first of all I mean I
think one of the most offensive things
in your intro was that you don't think
Joe brand dysfunctional areas I think
she has a style of humor but you know it
kind of ambushes you it takes a
handbrake turn down the dark alley I
think she's brilliant but there are two
things that go on with with comedy one
of them is context and - and the second
one is whether you punch up or you punch
down now for a little bit of Cox let's
just have a look at something that Tom
Walker said he is better known as
Jonathan pie you have to remember when
these sorts of incidents happen and
they're coming up more and more in this
sort of rather puritanical age that we
seem to be entering people seem to
willfully forget
tent and context all right so let's look
at the context if you listen to the clip
the context is there for you people
laugh at it right it's clearly a joke
did Joe brand intend for someone to
throw acid on a politician's face and if
you really believed that she wanted that
that she was really inciting that then I
think you all probably wilfully
misinterpreting the context with which
she said it see I think that that joke
was willfully misinterpreted you know it
was that outrage moment that seems to
happen so often in this country lately
it was very very clear in the context of
the joke and she actually said
afterwards but she was joking that she
didn't mean it so for anyone to
misinterpret that you are doing so
deliberately I have no briefer drug
brand by the way to complain but a long
time ago I refused to give her a job
which is true but I think to be fair to
her you said we should maybe listen to
what she said and how she said it
because I think that's to your point
Rachel okay certain unpleasant
characters are being thrown to the fore
and they're very very easy to hate and
I'm kind of thinking why bother with a
milkshake when you could get some
battery acid
that's just me and I'm not gonna do it
it's purely a fantasy but I think
milkshakes are pathetic Joe Brendan
radio for their magic we're not got your
book yes I just want to tell you what
the BBC said if we have a look it says
that in their defense they said heresy
is a long-running comedy program where
panelists often say things which are
deliberately provocative and go against
societal norms but are not intended to
be taken seriously we carefully consider
the program before broadcast it was
never intended to encourage or condone
violence and it does not do so but we
have noted the strong reaction to it and
then of course in that age-old la
tried-and-tested line where you regret
any offence what surprised us we'll know
what you say about Joe Brendo many bad
no I I don't I didn't find the joke
funny I don't think she should have
cracked the joke but I don't believe in
certainly don't believe that she should
have been prosecuted for it not a great
harm and I think she cut it well they
she I mean they edited that program it
should not have been included precisely
we're awesome
once we forged of course I don't believe
in censorship once the decisions been
made
okay Michelle sorry van got you so I
agree with you entirely although I must
make a very important disclosure I've
never had a terrible case of pile so I
can't compare Joe Brown's level of humor
to that I don't think what she said was
a joke in any way shape or form I think
it was an unacceptable comment I fail to
understand in any context in any
intention how throwing acid in someone's
face could even be even remotely amusing
and there's been 2,000 acid attacks over
the last three years in this country
throwing acid at somebody has become
more and more of a thing if you don't
like them if you want to rob them if you
want to disagree with them whatever it
is it's now become some form of norm to
throw acid on people what she referenced
it in a jerky context just be clear it's
ridiculous now this is ridiculous there
are more sort of things now we cannot
now refer to unpleasant behavior in case
it encourages someone behave it is
unacceptable listen to a lady who's had
acid thrown in her face as well and see
her
a little lady called Sophie hole and
what she's saying here as she spoke to
the Daily Mirror
what she's saying is that George had
never of Jarrett's bet in the first
place because it's not a joking matter
there are people out there who's
suffered before and for her to make a
remark like that it's just so upsetting
Jay I should go and go to a bands unit
and see what it does and see if she can
make a joke about it afterwards after
seeing the trauma people have gone
through so I just don't I don't agree
that this was in any way shape of John I
just have one for me there imagine I
mean it just so I'm a slightly Trevor
until the politician got murdered I was
with you I just think until we can dial
down the anger that's abroad and whether
its extinction rebellion whether it's we
should leave what we should remain this
such anger that we have to be aware once
that dissipates the Michelle's just
raised I mean I think the the victim of
acid attack there would be saying that
that was also punching down for example
in her view I that happens particularly
in my community it's a very very serious
problem now I'm not saying to repeat
that she shouldn't have been that she
should have been somehow punished for
this but I'm saying that there's a
serious lack of consistency you know
when that when Joe Cox was tragically
murdered you know she was murdered by
someone who was a far-right extremist
who who had believed one of the reasons
that he singled her out was because she
was Pro immigration if we're gonna be
consistent
then let's be consistent about not
attacking immigration in our national
conversation to such an extent this is
ridiculous Nick since I was six years
old people have made war jokes in front
of me and at me up until this year do I
say that everybody who does that needs
to get sacked no that's ridiculous and
second and secondly this is more
important is the more important point
what you guys seem to be saying and I I
think it's unfortunate to bring in the
experience of somebody who has had
something really ghastly happened to
them in in order to say that a comedian
I mean these people are not serious
people let's not keep start treating
entertainers like MAIF matter that they
have audiences yeah but but
you know that's what my radio show and
Magic Johnson we're trying to tile
demonstrating the gesture as if the
gesture is the king the more you do that
the more you make them important and the
more you make this kind of thing the
issue every time it happened and what is
now happening is that people are
increasingly not able to express a point
of view and then we get arguments about
how boring was that debate because
they're all careful they're also not
saying anything that they really mean
now what do you want do you want to be
in a liberal democracy or do you want to
be in North Korea